and she was she uh had a pen and was
about to poke a hole because that's what
you do whoa
held her back because they didn't know
what she was trying to do and he died oh
my God
[Music]
so a woman was uh arrested recently at
Harry Reid airport AKA McCarran Airport
AKA Las Vegas Airport why did it change
the name it's like during the time where
like all the statues and [ __ ] were
getting taken down you know we gotta
rewrite the history so I don't know what
the hell the McCarran guy did apparently
they don't like them and they like this
Harry Reid guy he was just a senator
who's juicing his own [ __ ] like like
usual if you're in office for long
enough you get to name [ __ ] after
yourself but they he kind of this kind
of happened after he was already out of
office but still it was like a hookup oh
so it's not McCarran anymore no but they
didn't do a good job because all over it
says like McCarran and then this is
Harry Reid so they didn't there's like
signs they're still confusing it's
confusing yeah so a woman was arrested
for being too hot
oh no and there's a lot of hot women in
Vegas so she must be really hot she's a
smoker for sure smoke show she just
walked by the slot machines and money
just starts spitting out it's it's a
little bit like that like ATM is just a
malfunction around a lot a lot of money
comes out like that's something you
would never want scrubbed from your
record
yeah for being too hot yeah all the guys
are like cat calling her all the time
would you guys like to see her yeah
first of all I need to tell you who says
that she got arrested for being too hot
hey dude so I already know she's like
60. no no believe all women on this side
okay that's exactly it believe all I
don't know Ryan's new to that side you
sure he's with you damn you're on the
side I literally never believe women my
allies over there and you know here
outside you're sitting on
okay I don't know what you guys think
but I I only see beautiful people all
day every day so there's no ugly in my
eyes there's nothing but beautiful so
what so what so what all right it's all
these WP files whatever that's her okay
there's a glare okay she's pretty oh
she's pretty yeah
where's those what are those girls on
the left doing that's her too oh
dude
nice lives if you're but but if you're
gonna claim you're the hottest woman on
Earth
she's dead
like you can't just be average pretty
you didn't say she's a hot woman on
earth she just said she got arrested for
a bit I don't like girls that wear
lanyards dude I'm out lanyards no okay
no yeah what about like event staff no
convention you're not school convention
too she's addicted to access yeah
uh no so she was she was uh hanging out
at the Chili's at McCann a beautiful
Chili's by the way really worth the top
five chilies yeah great chili because
that's one of the hottest people hang
out okay she was there she was getting a
little toasted getting a little lit up
getting an awesome Blossom getting a
little bit of a couple of my ties couple
of maybe strawberry mimosas okay then
she decides to dine in ditch oh no
that's what hot people do she just walks
out away from the table some guy said
she was gonna pay for it no he was like
I got you sweetheart she's like the
world takes care of me never coughed up
I don't like it so then
um
the police are notified at the airport
then a search begins maybe she's like
I'll Fly Away they'll never catch me
that's what you'd think she was actually
just sleeping next to like some trash
cans for some reason dude she must have
been way [ __ ] too much yeah so then
lounge access the cops the cops tap her
and like hey you dined in ditch we're
replacing under arrest right now she
threatens to spit on them she says
you're just arresting me because I'm too
hot yeah and she was right huh and she
was right yeah and the court and the
court says that she was right yeah no so
she's um the justice system she's she's
being processed right now she also had
an outstanding warrant from a Las Vegas
Municipal Court and she was booked into
Clark County Detention Center for
misconduct she's currently being held on
one thousand dollars a bail
I wanna I wanna be arrested for being
too hot somewhere like like hey you're
under arrest why for being too hot oh
really that's cool yeah why does Las
Vegas prosecute their criminals I think
that's stupid
what do you think they should do I think
they should let them go like what are we
doing I think they should give them a
Stern warning after they murder three
people and go don't do it again buddy
dude okay bye dude dining and ditching I
know the airport is a victimless crime I
know because you know they're up
charging you're [ __ ] everything in
that restaurant you know especially a
corporation like Chili's dude I'm
against course it's 14 really yeah go
[ __ ] yourself that's crazy she all the
only crime she committed was committing
a crime in a state that will actually
prosecute yeah
that's where you messed up yeah she
should have done it in LA Honolulu New
York everywhere else I wonder how much
Her tab was she could have dined ditched
made it across the California border
scot-free for sure and then the police
here would have been like hey
we [ __ ] help criminals here I still
just don't get the logic just claimed
Asylum like you're arresting me because
I'm hot I don't get it like what what
how was that a problem she's being
discriminated and chosen because she's
so hot wait was we can't possibly
understand what's going on it could be
that she was being arrested by a female
cops
so that's what she played women love
doing that
at Clark County Municipal Court she
claimed that she was being arrested by a
bunch of fives
[Laughter]
so the FAA basically says um unruly
passengers are nothing new we're kind of
been dealing with the uptick and unruly
passengers in the airports getting into
trouble on flights and in airports
especially with the people that are like
fighting the masks and stuff oh my God
every flight every flight there's
someone arguing about that [ __ ] yeah
well now they don't because they don't
have to but yeah that was a big part
that was just the air marshal trying to
blend in
he's doing way too yeah good job he was
selling it hell chill man he's like well
I hope they got an Air Marshall on this
flight we're gonna need them
we're gonna need that [ __ ] hero it's
you isn't it it's you trying to point
the blame ready yeah yeah they all try
to look for the air marshal I've tried a
couple times but I'm like man I can't
not look but look like the air marshal I
tried to do that oh you try to look like
it what do you do like there's guns
uncomfortable in my waistband
dude you know the easiest way to do it
is to make an announcement that you're
the air marshal yeah guys we're gonna be
safe on this flight I am the air marshal
you're gonna see a guy go
[Laughter]
es
I could have seen one or I he's pretty
much probably one because when I was
exiting the airplane you know how like
you go on that little [ __ ] connector
thing right yeah you know how that
corner sometimes they pile like your
luggage so you could go and there's a
door there or the stroller yeah right
there right so we're getting out plain
clothes guy just goes opens the door
gets out that way by himself no one says
anything cool so I was like oh [ __ ] did
he look like how did he look did he look
like he could have [ __ ] up a terrorist
or something he looked like a cop like
he looked like an older like middle-aged
white guy with like a leather jacket he
was bald yeah yeah he's just he looked
like if he put on a cop uniform you
would be like yeah he's a cop isn't it
that some flights have more than one as
well
I've heard that like sometimes there's
up to three on one plane wow and every
fly has one right every fly has a fly
Marshal everyone does but I know
International ones and they're armed
right they have like guns yeah so if
they shot the gun wouldn't we all be
[ __ ] anyway you lose pressure in the
cabin I'm like we're almost get sucked
out of hole
I saw Snakes on a Plane dude yeah no it
just sucks us up and then one of us goes
and then plug it with our shoulder oh
yeah I will say on my last flight coming
back from Turkey they went on the
intercom they're like is there a doctor
here and then the dude was sitting next
to me he told the flight attendant he's
like he's like oh I'm a doctor like what
do you guys need and then she was like
do you have your doctor ID or papers
he's like no she's like
we can't use you and then they went off
yeah that's true why did someone need a
doctor I don't know just somebody like
10 rows back maybe having a breathing
problem or something they're like you're
too hot we got to use another an ugly
doctor ma'am ma'am can you breathe
listen we think we we thought we found a
doctor but we don't think he has the
credentials we have your back
please
anyway what do they look like no the I
told this story here right when
um I was flying back to Vegas this guy
almost
um died on the landing he had a seizure
so in that moment when they're like we
need a medical professional to come
there were people already helping them
and then they're like oh can I check
your credentials and then everyone just
busted like it was like protocol like
everyone had their little cards oh so
they know and then some people had it in
their wallets and then they just held it
out and then so and then the the flight
attendant just had to kind of read it
and be like okay okay I was on a cruise
ship and a guy was [ __ ] choking like
like the typical movie choking thing and
they're like oh my God is there a doctor
and we didn't even see where the guy was
and I stood up because I'm [ __ ] tall
and I saw him and the doctor raced over
and then there was like a woman who was
like talking to him and then he was like
gesturing like he doesn't have his
wallet and then the guy [ __ ] died
whoa yeah because because they wanted to
see identification
that really happened that was actually a
true story but but I kind of Juiced it
at the end
the guy didn't die
that that didn't happen and then uh yeah
it was a shrimp cocktail paprika but I
was on a cruise yeah I was on a cruise
the doctor call did happen I did stand
up I was the only person who could see
it and then it was fine but they didn't
ask him for if he was because I think
we're choking that's like a first aid
thing yeah say your CPR certified or
something there was a real story of uh
he was a Filipino doctor at our church
and uh his wife is also a doctor and
that happened to him where he was
choking at a restaurant and she was she
uh had a pen and was about to poke a
hole because that's what you do whoa
held her back because they didn't know
what she was trying to do and he died oh
my God yeah I think there was a loss
yeah the Heimlich it was too late the
guy would be like don't worry somebody
tried to kill you with the pen but got
your back
it wasn't a uh heimlich is only for you
if your air passage is blocked by
something this was I believe a allergic
reaction my clothes [ __ ] so when that
happens you have to make a passage and
she was trying to do it and they just
kept pulling her back like don't kill
him and he he really [ __ ] died yeah
[ __ ] she wasn't saying I have to do this
you need to yeah she they were both
[ __ ] doctors isn't that crazy I
wonder what those dumb ass [ __ ]
staffers were thinking afterwards
they're like I hope I don't get fired
oh
foreign
[Music]